外部
[音楽]
アクティブなライブ ストリーム番号
50.0 へようこそ。2022 年 10 月 17 日です。
制御としてのアロスタシスのモデル化としてのインターセプションに関するシリーズを開始し
ます。アクティブな推論研究所へようこそ。私たちは、学習と通信を行う参加型のオンライン研究所です。
適用された能動的推論の実践
これはアーカイブ ライブ ストリームに記録されている
ので、フィードバックを提供して作業を改善できるようにしてください
すべての背景と視点を
歓迎し、今日の 50.0
でライブ ストリームの適切なビデオ エチケットに従い
ます このシリーズの議論を開始します
コントロールとしてのアロスタシスのモデル化としての論文インターセプト
著者は Eli synesh Jordan
therealt Dana Brooks John wilheim Von
DeMint Lisa Feldman Barrett と Karen s
Quigley
です.
ディーンとしてのビデオはこちらです。私
はこの論文に取り組み、いくつかの
関連トピックについて説明します。
いくつかの大きな
問題について検討し、論文の基本的な目的と抽象的な
ロードマップを検討
し、いくつかの重要なポイントと画像とテーマについて論文に触れて
から、主に
著者や希望する他の人と議論することを楽しみにしています
ダニエルです。私はカリフォルニアの研究者です。
この論文は分散型の賛成票によって選ばれ
ました。読むのはとても楽しかった
し、私たちの注目の体制にいくつかの新しいトピックをもたらした
ので、探しています これ
をディーンに渡します
チャーリーに感謝します 私はディーンです ここ
カルガリー
にいます
物事が組み合わさったときに何が起こるかを調べようとするのは
、私がいつも
興味を持っていることです。実際、それは
これのタイトルであり、
アロスタシスと
テレセプションが一緒になったという事実と、何が何をするのかということです。
それが、私がこれに少し時間を費やした理由であり
、
著者がこのアイデアを正しく機能させるようになった今、著者が何を言わなければならないかを聞くことに非常に興味
があります。大きな問題をどのようにうまく説明できますか
? つまり、ここでの焦点は
、何が起こるか、そしてさまざまな程度の複雑さの生理学的タスクを実行する
ために必要なコントローラーの要件について私たちが言える
ことだと思います.ええと、さまざまな結果と行動の特異性が全体としてどのように見えるか本当に確信したことはありません.
私
たちが言えることの1つ
は、予測コンポーネント
とフィードバックコンポーネントが
あり、それらがその2つの特定のタイプに焦点を当てている場合です.
ええと、興味深いのは、おそらくどのような
一般性を
無視できるかということです.
井戸の雑草の中で迷子にならないように、これは
あちこちで起こりましたが、
ちょうどその一般的なレベルで
、これら2つのことを組み合わせると、どのようなこと
が起こりますか
ええと、特定のパターンまたは
共通性として
いいと言うべきでしょうか。私はそれを
、特定のシステムに
依存し
ない、またはモダリティに依存しない、生理学の
予測的変化であるアロスタシスのような現象
がドメイン
または傍受のようなユースケースにどのように接続するかを尋ねるカテゴリーに入れることに同意します 私
たちが探求してきたモデルの多くは、
視覚的、
概念的、または象徴的なもので
あり、傍受のモダリティは
議論の中
で
何度も出てきているよう
です。
先に説明した論文 出版物ページで著者
によって書かれたハイライトのほんの一部
インターセプトにより、脳
は体の今後の代謝ニーズを予測することができ
ます インターセプトは
、内臓運動調節のパフォーマンス指標を提供します
制御理論を意思
決定および運動制御と結び付けます 体の
アロスタティック
制御を、時間とともに変化する最適な制御としてモデル化します
彼ら
は、以前のモデルのいくつかの制限と、
彼らのモデルが行うことのいくつかのユニークな側面、
および彼らが頂点モデルを定式化する方法について話してい
ます。
この比較的
長く
、技術的に足場が組まれた論文の議論の中で、一握りの本当に重要で顕著なもの
を引き出し
、点と点を結び付けて設定された書かれたクレームの束を引き出したとき
形式主義に関連する解釈のいくつかは、
それらのいずれかを強調したいですか、それとも
、これをやめたいと思っている人のためにそれらを持っていても問題ありませんが、ここでこれを言い
ます。
ここで
予測の間
予測 ええと 処理 いいえ 予測処理と言っているのではなく
、予測デバイスとして処理しています
感情
、制御、フィードバック
など、多くの主張ができると思います
が、それは本当に
微妙なニュアンスがあり、非常に
複雑
で、遊ぶためのスペースなので
、なぜ
たくさんあるのか理解できます
繰り返しになりますが、それらの
主張が崩壊する前にそれらの主張がどこまで保持
できるかどうか、または著者と話すのは興味深いことです。
ええと、それは非常に絡み合った
領域である
と言いました
私は髪の毛がたくさんあるので、それ
は私にとってはトリッキーです
わかりました
要約 わかりました 最初の 3 つを読みます 脳は身体のニーズを予測し、それらが生じる前に満たそうとすることで体を調節します アロスタシス アロスタシスと呼ばれるプロセスには、
体内の感覚状態を変化させる
この論文ではインターセプションと呼ばれるプロセスであり、インターセプションがアロスタシスのパフォーマンスフィードバックをどのように提供するかを調べます。
制御理論の実効値 生理学の運動制御および意思決定における
関連する問題への制御理論の適用を検討
する 制御問題としてのアウトスタティック制御の重要な特性にそれらを関連付けることにより、これらを統合し、次に
、脳がどのようにアロスタティック制御を実行するかについての通常の形式をスケッチする
類推による内臓 2
数学的ビューを含む骨格運動制御
と、交差がアロスタシスのパフォーマンスフィードバックとしてどのように機能するか
最後
に、仮説の意味をテストする方法を提案
します それらの統合と解釈の重要な柱または基礎のいくつかを紹介します。
これは
、
生理学的運動制御の
意思決定
とアロスタシスを
確率的最適制御を追跡する軌跡として統合するためのアプローチとしての傍受制御理論です。
第5セクションは議論
であり、付録Bがあります。
カ 彼らの言葉を借りると、この論文の 4 つのセクションは
傍受をアロスタシスに結び付け
ます セクション 2
は、脳が現在の瞬間における体の生理学的効率を評価することを可能にする方法を立証します。
理論
セクション 4 では、制御理論の原則を適用して
、脳がどのよう
に生理学的軌道の望ましさを推定し、
将来の
規制決定を下すかについての新しいフォーマット モデルを
導き出します。
用語集を提供しますが、これは上に
移動され、もはや付録ではないため、付録は
ありません。
付録 B1 は
セクション 3 に関連
する数学的詳細を提供し、付録 C1 は
セクション 4 に関連する数学的詳細を提供します。
キーワードは傍受
アロスタシスと予測処理でした。
行きます
インターセプトとアロスタシスについては
、このドット ゼロでいくらか話す必要がありますが
、今後の議論と
予測処理のために、最近の良い
ストリームはライブ ストリーム番号 43 で、
マリア
もわかり
ました。
スクリーンショットが必要な場合
は、多くの単語の定義を含む命名表があるので、
ここに最初の命名用語の 1
から 25
を示します。次に、
命名用語の後半の 26 から
49 を示します。
彼らがそれを提供してくれたのは良いこと
であり、今後のセクションでうまく使用される
と言うのは興味深いことだと思います。あなたが
指摘したのは興味深いと
思います。 彼らが何をメッセージしたいのかという観点から、
この編み
こみは、少なくとも
物事が以前に何を意味するのかについて常識を得る必要があります。
私たちは
それらが等しいものを引き離そうとし始めます。
ええ、私はそのようなものを
よく言いました
セクション1の紹介
体内の脳の機能
わかりました この論文の始まりは刺激的です
ええと、単純なドッジボールのゲームをしてい
ます 脳は体のシステムを継続的に調整する必要があり、
ドッジボールのこのモチーフは再び戻ってき
ます。
左側に
は、安定した拡散アルゴリズムの実装された抱きしめた顔があり
ます。画像のプロンプトは
ドッジボールでした
スライドを作成して
いる間、これらの画像生成アフォーダンスのいくつかを使用してアクティブな推論に従事し、それが
うまくいく
ようにしました。ジェネレーターが
言ったことは、調整された結果であるということは本当に興味深いと思います。
これらのプロンプトのもつれを探していますが、
それぞれがどのような戦略を持っているかについては何も話しませんでした それらの
ええと、シルエットは現在採用
されており、同様に戦略が進行しているという暗黙の感覚があると思い
ます。
これらの本当に興味深いものをいくつかまとめると、
ええと、それはあなたがどれだけ深く行きたいかによると思います
あなた
は空間を次元化したい
ので、それは何ですか ええ、これ
は同じプロンプトです これは単なる別のものでした これは
もう少し
フォトリアリスティック
でもう少し
とらえどころのないものに似ています 彼らはドッジボールをしているのですか
はい
、彼らは大丈夫だと推測
しています 次のキーワードは、人々がここで定義を読むことができれば、あなたはそれを選ぶことができ
ますが、インターセプトとは何かを
よく考え
てみてください。 時々若い人
やすべての人
が感情の傘の下にそれらすべてを分類する
よう
なものです.
どうすればこれ
をできる限りシンプルに保つことができるのでしょうか？これらの信号を受け取るとき、
これらの感覚信号
は体内から発生します。これらは
あなたが感じる感情であり、ええと、
あなたがそれらをあなたの外の世界に結び付けるかどうかに関係なく
。
肌やあなたの縁
ええと、時々あなたはそうすることがあります あなたは
ちょうど腹痛で目を覚ます
ので、それは今日について何を意味しますか
いいですね
少し狭い
傍受は、参照対象を使用した
隠れた状態に関する観察と推論に言及していると言えます
それ
は体の外側のXタロットとは対照的に、体の内側のタロットにありますが、
おそらく
多くのぼやけもあり
、網膜が実際に行っていることは、
それ自体で推論を行っていること
であり、外の世界構造のどこで実際に推論を行っているのですか?
適切な傍受
内部モデルいくつかの画像を追加しまし
たが、それらは何
でしょうか。心理学者が多くの用語で傍受を含む内部モッズを参照するように、これを簡単に読んでみましょう。
内部モデルとは
何かを明確に定義することについて常に合意が得られているとは限らないため、これは重要だと思います 無意識の興味のようなものは
、この傘の具現化されたシミュレーションに適合するよう
です 概念とカテゴリー
は幻覚を制御
しました。 それが何を意味するのかさえわかりません.
脳と呼ばれるものに関係なく
、この論文では、世界でその身体の動的モデルを構築するという仮説が立てられています.予測シミュレーションと概念という用語を使用してい
ます。 誘拐に関して
は、信号が
オブジェクトを解釈しました。
そのモデルは何ですか。それが表現であり、内容が満たされているかどうかについて、別の大きな議論に巻き込まれないようにするにはどうすればよい
でしょう
か。
一回限りのデータが私たちにやってきて、私
たちのさまざまな感覚面に注がれています。
部屋の温度が上がるとわかる外からの破片があると思いますが
、悪いエビを食べたために体温も上がっている可能性があり
、熱がなくなったからかどうかを判断するのが難しい場合があり
ます アップまたは私の体が
炎症性のジェスチャーで反応しているかどう
かええ、それは
素晴らしいポイントです.
違いを生む原因または違いを生む違いと呼ばれる
こともあります.
ウイルス
対これ 免疫系のダイナミクスの変化
非常に
興味深い左
の画像は、左の画像が左の画像であるかどうかはわかりません
右の画像が実際
に道を進んでいる速度と
デマシオは、私たちが実際に何を説明し、何を追求できるかについて多くのことを話しているので、エンテロセプターモデルに曖昧さが欲しかったのはそのためです。
ecise 用語
とややあいまいなままであり
、この論文の著者は
神について
も少し話し
ます 何らかの生理学的調節のためのあなたの生理学的設定点の具現化された行動
が変更された場合、それは
再び外部調整の同じ機会
を持っ
ていません.
これについて著者と話し、なぜ
彼らがこのモダリティを研究
するのかは興味深い
でしょう。彼らがアリスと統合しようとしている計算またはシステムに依存しない現象
は
アロスタシスであり、彼らはこの用語を
アロスタシスが予測するものとして定義しています 変化する
ニーズ 優先順位を評価し
、組織を準備する アロスタシスと呼ばれるエラーにつながる前にそれらを満足
させるためのプロセスなので、部屋
の温度のアロスタティック モデルがあり、深部
体温は
変化しないとだけ言っ
ておきましょう。 変化することが予想
され
ていたので
、体温が上昇しなかったので、それが機能
した
ことをどの
ように知っているかを誰かがうまく言うでしょう. 常にここで最小値について話している
ここでこれ
を行うために必要な最小値は何か
4 つまたは 5 つではなく 3
つがそれをより小さなスライスに分割する理由は、まったく興味深いことではありません。
正式なモデリングの詳細に飛び込む前に、著者が書いたすべての適切なアクティブな推論について著者と話し
たいと
思います。
ここでのアプローチ
と著名なモデリング フレームワークの
アクティブな推論を比較対照してください。
これらの詳細のいくつかに戻る予定です。
それについては多くの議論があると
思いますが、どのように準備するかについて非常に興味深い点を指摘し
てくれました。 彼らは
モデルをダウンストリームとして扱ったり
、特定の物理学へのコミットメントの結果として扱ったりしていません。これ
は、自由エネルギーの
原理、基本的に力学についてよく耳にする方法
ですが
、
モデルを一次構造として扱っており、
追加したいものです。
それは本当にそうだと思ったので
、論文の内容を組み立てるのに役立つ
と思いました ええ、それはストリートの部分です 文献の
ほとんどの積極的な関心モデルとは異なり、作業の弾丸は
以下の資料であると思います 無
期限または無限のホライズンコントロール設定
が興味深いため これにより、
彼らが
話していることと、多くの表現でよく見られる t0 との間が非常に明確になります。
順番に何が起こっているかを把握できるという点でT1からTまで何
でもいいので
、導入のこのセクションでは
、他のモデルに関するいくつかの問題
について説明します。
これらの決定がどのように制定されるかを考慮せずに問題を起こします。
これには
さまざまな解釈がありますが、
たとえば、ポリシーの列挙と
ポリシーからの選択を
必要とするか、運動コマンドが他の問題からどこから来るかを考慮せずに運動制御の問題として要求される可能性
があります
モデルは、代謝効率を目的として扱うのではなく、
ホメオスタシスについて議論
します 身体変数の調節 エラーに対する固定許容範囲でセットポイントを修正する
ため、これは本当にクールなテーマになり
、セットポイントと変動性を修正するのではなく、
その結果を
アトラをもたらす他のプロセスによるものである
固定された設定
点とエラーに対する経験的な許容範囲、および
おそらくいくつかの戻り値のないポイントなどを使用して設定またはポイントを計算
します
が、これらすべての結果を、
実際には設定点を追求するのではなく、
むしろ動的システムの実現と見なします
私たちが探求するグラフの傾きを追求し、進化の時間
にわたる最大制御可能性のゾーンと最大制御可能性のゾーンの周りの驚きの減少は
、この種の生存
変数
と関連するようになり、他のいくつかのポイントは何でも大丈夫です
ええと、それは関係関係
関係であり、彼らはこの
論文がこのギャップを埋めることを目的
とし
ていると言います. ターゲティングについて話し
ます 彼らは
関係がここ
で起こっていると彼らが考える重要な役割を果たしていると考えているという事実について考えます
彼らはおそらくギャップが
続いています.彼らは私たちが検討し熟考するためにここに何かを入れているということですが
、
私たちが実際にギャップを埋めて
いるかどうかはわかりません.
右側の
セクション 2 にスペースを空けます。セクション 2 の冒頭で
、効率を推定するボディをモデル化する上部のパラグラフ インターセプトを
示し、次に、折り目の下の
セクション 2.5 要約を示します。したがって、これらの
前と後の両方に 2.
ええと、2.0
2.2
には多くの構造情報が含まれています
このホワイト ペーパーのキー ポイントは
、この特定のスライドに追加
するものです。または、一番下のセクションに進みます。
人々はそれについて読みたいと思うかもしれません。
興味深いことに
、容量曲線の応答範囲に向かう動きは、特に神経回路やモジュールを特別に計算する
必要性を潜在的に排除する可能性がある
と
思います.
報酬コストの行動構造な
ので、生理学の
非報酬中心の
理解
や報酬の再解釈に移行すること
はどういう意味ですか?
内臓
感覚変数の切片
リソースの量を表すもの 規制された資源と
プロセスが行動する速度
を表すもの
枯渇性資源で
ある規制資源は
、ホメオスタシスのコンテキストにおける生理学の有界変数のようなものです。必ずしもそうとは限りません。
代謝物のような
枯渇性資源であり、血糖
やコア体温のような規制資源は、
物理量またはブドウ糖のような物質を表します。
瞬時に変えられないから さまざまな
モダリティのさまざまな調整されたリソースが何であるかを尋ねるの
は興味深い
と思います。次に、制御さ
れたプロセスは生理学的プロセスが動作する速度である
ため、その場合は
、血糖の入出力関係のようなものになります。
私
たちが最近話したのは
、グリッパーとグリップの違いであり、
両方が同時に存在できるということ
です
.2.2ドッジボールの例に戻ります.ドッジボールの例で述べたように、有酸素運動中は
心拍数と血圧が上昇する必要
がある
ため、
運動を開始し、休息状態で運動を継続するための何らかの生理学的適応である
圧力受容器心拍数
反射である圧受容器は、通常
、心拍数を遅くすることによって血圧の上昇に対抗し
ますが、運動を行うと、
血圧と心拍数の両方
をサポートするために増加する必要があります。
あなたの元に必要な血流の必要な増加
この種の反射の変調が
、血圧の
変化を心拍数の変化に関連付ける機能全体のシフトをどの
ように可能にするかについての
議論があります。
さまざまな生理学的変数の因果構造または相関構造
をかなり一般的にモデル化
する方法ですが、より具体的になるでしょう
ええと、そこに少しの共変動が
あり、ええと
、生理学とこれからは
大丈夫です 2.2
規制および制御
されたプロセスの範囲を予測およびモデル化する これ 曲線のパラメータのいくつかを記述している
部分的に導出される閾値と飽和点
生理学者が摂動と調節応答の間の関係をモデル化するために一般的に使用する関数から導出される曲線を定義する
通常、それらを応答曲線または
伝達関数
と呼び、容量という用語を付ける
強調するために曲線が使用されます その
ような曲線は、ある時点で時間の経過とともに変化する可能
性が
ありますが、有機体が利用できる制限された規制リソースの現在の範囲を表している
ため、ある時点で市場を維持するための財務能力曲線のように想像することができます。
しかし
類推する
と
、システムが摂動にどのように応答するかをモデル化するというこのアイデアは、
必ずしもそのシステムの内部モデルをモデル化する必要はありません。
ええと
、
システムには一種の摂動性があり、その構造
について強い仮説を立てずにシステムに
アプローチ
することができます。 関数 y を定義すると
、 U mu K が R Big B
であることを取り込んで、それらを
図 1 の方程式に結合します X 軸は
血圧
を示し、Y 軸はこの生理学的変数を調節
する反射のベースライン活性化パーセンテージを示している
ため、100 は目標
血圧または
恒常性設定点と呼ばれるものの一種です。
その時点でアトラクタの
ようです
対称
性の低下 血圧の調節の動的モデル
方程式 2 3 および 4.
生成モデルの形式の概要
観測されていない変数に関して観測された変数を確率論的に予測するための手順
リストされ
ている変数は、A プライオリ確率からサンプリングされた観測されていない変数です
分布は
データに依存しない
ため、generat を使用することを指してい
ます。
ここでの提案には
、平均動脈血圧 X の方程式
と、なぜバレル反射
活性化がベースラインのパーセンテージとして表されるかという珍しい特徴がある
ので、図 1 X と Y
または分位変数
U 変位値変数
は、
血圧とバレル反射
活性化の間の関係を
、容量曲線の動作点
mu とゲイン K の変化に関係なく一様に表し
ます 変位値は、パラメータではなく容量曲線の関数形式のみに依存するため、
展開します もう少し技術的にです
が、彼らはここでもモデルの特徴としてそれを指摘しています。
図1は少し大きく
、後で議論するスペースが増えています。
図
2は、図1の容量曲線
を青色で示し、線形化された応答
をオレンジ色で示しています。
ブルー ダイアモンド マーカーの動作点付近で、
これをこのシグモイド曲線の最大の正の勾配として見ることができ
、
反射が
シグモイド的に活性化されるという仕様の下では
、上に曲がる部分と下に曲がる部分のどちらにいるのか、
または
最大の正の勾配
を追求し、そのポイントを追求して
報われると考えるかによって異なります。 最大の操縦性と制御への動きによって
、これは定点アトラクタのような恒常性モデルを追求することと同等に
なるため、ボウルの底の種類
をこのオレンジ ラインに配置し
、ブルー ダイヤモンドが
減少するのではなく、勾配が最大化されます。  100 からの距離です。そうです、
このセクションを 2 回コピーしたと思います
。2 回コピーしたのは非常に珍しいことでした。はい 2.3 ドッジボールの例に戻り
、バロー反射血圧だけでなく、
酸素グルコースの循環レベルまで範囲を広げようとしています。
次に、制御されたリソースとしての血糖に焦点を当て
、グルカゴンを
制御されたプロセスとしての分泌を可能にします
血液中へのブドウ糖と、血液から
のブドウ糖の除去を可能にする制御プロセスとしてのインスリン。
したがって、バレル
反射は、単一のボリューム ノブ
または単一の応答を下げたり上げたりできるトリアージ ナース
のようなものでした。
取り除かれた
グルコース調節には複数のホルモン
が含まれているように見えます.2つの異なる側面からわずかに異なる方法で緩衝されるようになります
が、多くの同じ
形式とロジック
を使用して、わずかに
異なるより複雑な生理学的
システムを導入します.
血糖値は
、生物学的に
ハードコードされた設定点で積極的に防御されていない.
心拍数が代わりにグルカゴンとインスリンである.2つの
ホルモンの
活動は、互いの効果のバランスを取り
、血糖値を
その安定範囲内の点にもたらし
、ブドウ糖が
人が食物とブドウ糖を摂取した後
、血液から他の身体へと渡る
組織の機能をサポートするための組織
このスライドに追加するもの
は特にありません セクションの最後まで待ってください
2 番目の 2
つについて
彼らが書いている図 3 です 図 3
は、この方程式を適用した結果の関数のプロットを示しています
容量曲線として解釈できるインスリンの場合
オレンジ色のシグモイドは
インスリン 青色のシグモイドはグルカゴン
血中のブドウ糖のレベルである異なる x 軸で異なるホルモンレベルを持っているため
、ブドウ糖が高いときの見慣れた行動が見られます
次に、インスリンの分泌
が高くなり、グルコースの吸収が促進さ
れ、この場合、グルコースが
2.5 または 3 程度を下回ると、
グルカゴンが分泌されて、グルコース
が血中に入るように誘導されます。
したがって、グルコース
レベルが振動していると想像できます。
セクション 2.4
は、この種の規制措置の議論から移行する場所です。
実行可能な範囲と能力
を明らかにすることは、モジュラー報酬システムを不要にする可能性があります
ここに神経解剖学への議論またはアピールが
あります 食欲または嫌悪の強化値
を具体的にコード化する単一の脳部位はありません
離散報酬および決定システムをドメインとして再構成することは有用です
一般的なアロスタティック制御
システム ドメインの傍受の一般性は、
精神モジュールや機能を必要としないという考えをさらに理論的にサポートし
ます 心理学
脳がどのように機能するかを理解するため
の概念 神経
系
とこのトピックについてもう少し追加するものがある
ので、37 に進みましょう。
制御の報酬は
わかりました。ここで、Tobias Norville が関与する 2 つの論文の素敵な画像を紹介したい
と思います。これらの論文は論文で引用されています。
議論中であり、それらはすべてかなりのインテを示しています
これらのグラフのいくつかを強調するためだけに、これらのグラフのいくつかを強調するために、
ここではグルコースと温度空間内の動きを示しています。
左下の複数の生理学的変数の調節は
、傍受の恒常性
設定点と運動コマンドの統合です。
ここでは採餌に関連するようなものです。
事前の事後的
可能性と、この
推論の双方向の関係と以前の
動的モデルについて 2 つの密度の話
と、最後の 1 つです。
このナプキンの形状は
、大理石
が特定のゾーンでほとんどの時間を過ごす
ように設計または進化または選択することができるボウルの
追加するものは何でもOK
セクション 2 では基本的に
、  o
ある種の
認識可能な有限限界と、
それらの限界が何であれ内の変動性に依存する、連続性の要素を持つ
あらゆる種類の予測パフォーマンスを行っていると思います。
一種の 2 要因の状況
で、このようなシグナルが
あり、彼らはバレル反射とグルカゴンの例をいくつか指摘しました。
これらの 2 つの例の複雑さを
保持しようとしていた点を維持
することは
、これらの
容量曲線を
調べ始める
ことを可能
にするものです。 章の要約の
このセクションで
は、工学制御理論から概念を紹介
し、生命科学におけるその応用を概説します。
生理学セクション 3.1 骨格
運動運動 セクション 3.2 および
意思決定セクション 3.3 セクション 3.4 では
、将来の傍受状態を
現在の動きに結び付け
ます。
インターセプトがアロスタシスをどのようにサポートするかを示唆するために、
ここでスライドのすべてを読むつもりはありません
が、これはセクション 3.1 からのもの
です
生理学の制御理論 信頼できる
信頼できないパーツから構築された信頼できるボディ
ええ
、コントローラー
がうまく機能するように呼びかけます。それに
は、プラントの予想される動作のある種のコピーまたはミラーが含ま
れている必要があります。内部モデル
制御理論家は、
駆動システムがプラントを支援し、その望ましい
軌道を参照します。 軌跡
とこの種のうーんのいくつかの興味深い議論が
あります
制御理論のスレッド
図
4 つまり、図 4 は
モデルベースの制御システム
の機能ブロック図です オレンジ色のプラントは、
モーションまたはその他の動作が
制御さ
れるオブジェクトまたはシステムです コントローラ 紫は信号を
制御します 実線のブロック
矢印 プラントの動き方を変更します そして
期待される結果の予測を
知らせます 黄色い実線の矢印が黄色の状態
推定器へと続きます 人々は
これらの数字の残りの部分を
読むことができます
モデルのさまざまな部分を
見て、人々が
2つのことがどのように一致しているかをリアルタイムで
見る
ことができるようにし
ます 23 巧みなパフォーマンス
と相互作用主義と指導主義と
モータープラントの考え方
など 右
セクション 3.2 体を動かす
リファレンスコントロール仮説
参照制御仮説
提供された引用は Feldman 2015
および latash 2021 で
あり、参照制御仮説
は、脊髄の下位レベルの反射への参照軌道を処方する脳内の高レベルのコントローラーを備えたコントローラーの階層の観点から骨格運動システムを説明してい
ます。 次に、反射は、求心性固有受容ニューロンによって
信号が送られる筋肉の実際の長さと、
脳によって送信された参照長とを比較し
、筋肉を収縮させて
2 つを一致さ
せます。フェルドマンの 2015 年の本の目次の上部は次のとおりです。
行動と知覚の指示対象制御​​と、
ライフレビュー2021の物理学におけるラタッシュの論文と、
このタイプのアプローチに関するいくつかのグラフィックス 外国のこのタイプの
アプローチ
については、このスライドから始めることができ
ます。
彼ら
はここで過適合であると非難されたくないので、
あなたの運動制御を始めてください 実験は
、運動制御の実際の構造との
限られたオーバーラップのみであるため、到達行動に関する限定的なオーバーラップ実験のみ
が、
実験
者が参加者に到達タスクを処方することを含みます 参加者の
脳は、実験者からの指示に従うために特別に機能するのでは
なく、むしろ自分の体を調整するために機能します
中枢神経系の実際の組織化は、体
の運動機能の動きを裏返しに見ることでよりよく発生します。
つまり、
体性体性運動経路は
、例えば、Dr 値を持つゲームで
、硬いまたは鋭いブロックを予期せず踏ん
だり、または オブジェクトは、通常、それ
を踏んだ自分自身を故意に突き刺すことはありません。
そのため
、私の焦点はまだ姿勢を安定させることにある可能性があるため、今は足を通り抜けたかっただけ
です。
組織の損傷により、次に何をすべきかを決定する必要があります。
彼らが言っていることを制限しようとしているという事実は、
これの目標部分が
良いこととして当てはまると言える範囲
だと思います。
指令システムや制御システムと需要システムとの間のこの関係は
何
ですか? たとえば、体が
軽度の低体温症にかかり始め、脳が正常に機能しなくなった
ことを人々が知っている場合などです。
たとえば
、スラーピーの頭痛がするので
、スラーピーを下に置いて飲むのをやめると、
それが効果であることを知っているので、それと
、この時点または時点で凍傷になっていることを知らない手足があることをどのように区別しますか?
少なくとも
私たちにとってはそうではないことを願っています。あなたがあなたを止めないように、ボタンは動き続け
ます。あなたは一緒に動きを止めることを避けます。
これは
本質的に死です。
あなたの
脳が死んでいる場合は死んでいるが、
手が死んでいるか、まだ
生きている場合、
コマンドセンターの結果とデマンド
センターの結果の明確な違いは、用語で何を意味するのかという議論に入る必要はありません。
大丈夫、最も危機的な状況の
いくつかで自分自身を生き続けるために自動的に行うことが起こります.
それ
はあなたのよう
ではありません.あなたの手は脳を持っています.
たとえば、誰かがあなたの救助に来るまで、あなたを十分長く生かしておくことができる
ので、それが混乱を招くかどうかはわかり
ませんが、和解はあると思います
が、それは命令と要求の間で行われ
、おそらく制御の一部です
新しい応答があなたを引き継いで生き続けるために
、コマンドされた時間をあきらめる能力です.コマンドセンターからそれを行う方法を必ずしも知っているとは限りません.
これについては著者と話さなければなりません。
なぜなら、これらの
質問は、私が少し生理学的な背景を持っているからです。
これらの極端な状況について疑問に思うからです。
セクション 33 将来の参照軌道を構築する意思決定を行い
ます。
彼らは要求という言葉を使用します。
それについては後で話します。スクリーンショットを撮り
たい人のために、three three からの引用をさらに引用します。
エルゴニシティについて
は、付録 B で説明しますが、ここでは取り上げません。
図 5 を読んでください。
実験のための機能ブロック
図 運動制御の実験心理学者のタスク指向の
図 この図は概念レベルでの正式な論理
構造を示し
ています 図 4 とは対照的に、ボックスと矢印は脳や神経系の解剖学的構造にマッピングされていません
この
図は、骨格運動
脳
と末梢伸展反射
コントローラー、および感覚状態
推定器である脳と末梢神経を区別しています。  al sense
organs 感覚面 感覚
面 図は工学
的観点を示し
ている 心理学
実験では、実験者
が参加者に行動のタスクを指示する
ので、外部性が
あり、参加者の脳
が行動を達成するための制御システムとして機能することに注意することが重要です
身体を維持する所定の行動システム したがって
、身体を動かすシステムに働き、身体
を動かすシステムは、所定の行動に役立ちます。
再び
規範に
焦点を
当てます。 図5とは対照的に、アロスタシスの
この図は
、体の自律的調節と
実験者の望ましいタスク行動のために設計された閉ループ制御システムを示して
います。
内部の受付 状態推定器
と
その推定値を更新するための予測誤差を受け取る
更新された推定値は
ビジター運動制御装置への基準信号として発行される
この図は正式な
論理構造を示す 概念レベル
描かれた仮説
は Bear 2017 で推測された解剖学的構造によって制約される
しかし、ボックスと矢印は
繰り返しをマッピングしません 脳や神経系の解剖学的構造に 1 対 1 でマッピングしません
大丈夫です ここでの違いを強調するために
、左はほとんど
教育者のようです
アレンジメントとこれが
実験心理学者の方法です このタスクについて考える
と、タスクの擬似コードが
心拍数をこの範囲内に保つように指示を書き留めているようなものです。
次に
、意識的な行動とストレッチが可能か、それとも潜在意識で行動できる
かを Skeletor モーター システムで決定
します。 傍受
する身体または外界の生理学
ve state estimator は、骨格運動決定
の望ましい実装と一致します。
対照的に、タスク命令の役割は
いわば
、この制御理論に置き換えられます
右側にありますが、ここでは
スカラーモーター
意思決定コントローラーとは対照
的に
、実際には内臓モーター意思決定コントローラーがあります。 反射
制御理論ビューですが、それも
一般化し
ます オーケーを超えて、それは単なる別のビューだと思います
セクション 4 軌道追跡としてのアロスタシス
確率的最適制御
このセクションでは
、アロスタティックな意思決定の正式なモデルについて説明します
アロスタティック経路 積分制御 頂点
モデル
apic は、 コアと同じ
ように、概念
はボーの内部モデルとして機能します dy の感覚面の
アクション 概念
は、潜在的な行動の内部モデルとしても機能し、それらの
予測される結果
セクション 4.1
は、
セクション 2 が
容量曲線
を表す数学的形式から SOC 目的関数を駆動し、セクション 4.2 4.3 および 4.4 は
、この頂点モデルを洗い流して説明
します
4.1
容量曲線を
目的関数に変換する 上記の 1 や図 1
などの特定の容量曲線
は、縦軸の最大値であり
、最大の y
値で除算して範囲に正規化できるためです。  0
と 1 の間。このように正規化すると、確率論から
累積分布関数として解釈することができます。
これはまさに、
スリニバサンのラフリンとダブス
が、網膜
ニューロンとハエの発火を
予測コーディングの形式として解釈するために行ったことです。
CDF累積
分布関数の導関数が
確率をもたらす図1
これは確率分布を表すより一般的な方法であり
、縦軸の高さ
が PDF の尤度に対応します
が、容量曲線から導出された PDF の
場合は、相対的な応答性を表します。
摂動に対しては、この
ような分布を参照分布と呼びます。
これは、確率密度
関数である PDF と CDF 累積分布
関数の間の統計分布の変換です
一部の人にとっては非常によく知られているかもしれません 一部の人にとって
はまったく新しいものかもしれないので、
それで十分です うまくいけば、これは 2 つ
の関係を検討
するのにまだ役立つので、これらの 3 つの画像の左側に
ある PDF は、確率分布を表すより一般的
な方法です。
これは一様分布であり
、6 分の 1 の確率で
6 面ダイス
またはほぼガウス ベル カーブの
状況での各結果 h これらの中央
と右の 2 つの画像の両方
が、ベル カーブの PDF を示しています。ベル
カーブであるため、PDF が最もよく知られ
ています。均一な分布は
、PDF のフラット ラインの
ようなものです。ベル カーブは、PDF のベル カーブのようなものです。
しかし、漸近的にのみ最大値と最小値を知っているので、
基本的に関数がその分布をサポートできる限り低く開始する累積分布関数を作成でき、累積的に
累積するだけな
ので、質問に答えるのに役立ちます。
3 分の 2 である 4、3、2、または 1 つを取得する確率、または 2 未満の
z スコアを取得する確率 (
2 つの標準偏差など)
正の曲線のどの部分が
PDF のその z スコアを下回っているか これ
は
、この CDF のポイントをすばやく調べるだけで対処
できます
。PDF と CDF の間の関係は、
サイコロを振ったり、評価したりするのと同じように、よりよく知られていることがわかります。 教室の高さは、
前述の容量曲線で使用して、最大化
されたときに最大制御のこの場所にある分布に移動する
ことができます.
曲線の形とそれ
は、このオレンジ ラインが最大化されていることで示唆されていたことのようなものです
オレンジ ラインが最大化されているの
は、この
ベル カーブの頂点ですが、古典
的なベルクロではありませんが、山
です。 あなたは
オンになっているので、分析の利便性のために非常に簡単に最適化
できます
。2006 年の tedorov から
、対数密度を PDF 自体ではなく PDF の対数を目的関数として使用する方法を取り入れています。
操作点は、引き続き
極大値として表示されます。 一方、ゲイン
は、動作点から離れる移動のコストと、
それに向かう移動の値を決定します。 図 8 は
、目的関数 log de を示しています。
元のバレル
反射容量曲線に対応する nsity
図 9
は、3 つすべてを並べて表示することにより、さまざまな形式の容量曲線間の関係をさらに明確にします。
これは
、図の左上にある非常に素晴らしい図です。
血圧
を調節するためにダイアルアップまたはダイアルダウンされる CDF として解釈
されると PDF
が生成され、残差を計算する代わりに最大化できる単一のピークで
ある この曲線の形状は、
計算上最適化するためにわずかに良くなります
このような逆漏斗のような形ではなく、
より滑らかなボウルの
よう
になるようにすると、より詳細に説明できますなぜそれがクールだと思うの
か、なぜこの丸太のステップが
重要なのか、それとも重要なのかを言うだけで十分です
これは
、シグモイド
ジャグリング行為
をマウンテン クライム
テーブルに変えることを可能に
する大きな動きです。
私たちのグラフィカル モデル
が脳の解剖学的構造を正確
に捉えているとは主張しません タイム スケール
の階層全体で参照ベースの感覚運動制御を捉えます
テーブル内の脳変数と共有される単一の特徴
瞬時のキャプチャ レートに関する方程式 5 と 6
ドット 1.2
セクション 4.2 でそれについて議論する 最適な採餌について議論するのもいいでしょう
理論は
アロスタティック制御の関数形式を示唆して
います 最適な採餌について前もって何か追加したいですか?
それが何を
意味するの
か それが素晴らしいことを意味する 大丈夫 方程式
グローバル捕獲率
セクション 4.3 フィードバックまたは
生成的行動によるフィードフォワード制御
左セクションのアロスタティック容量
推定量
4.3
式 10 式 11.
その他の変数
stoc 図 10. これ
は、ニューラル階層に関する経験的
な質問に対処することなく、各レベルで複数の時間スケールと参照分布をキャプチャ
する階層的な生成モデルについて説明するのに適してい
ます。ここでは
、L が等しいモデルを使用します。 図6に一致する4つのモデル
は、これらのノードのいくつかが何を意味するかを定義します
が、y軸は時間スケールを増加させている
ため、おそらくより遅いものが
上にあり、右側にあるのは時間の経過です。
これは何を考えさせます
か?
私はスマートなアップルになろうとしているわけではありませんが、
L4が提供する情報は興味深いものだと思います。
4つ以上のレベルがありますが、
彼らは私のためにそれらに集中したいと思っています。
つまり、私の脳がどこに行くのかという
ことです。 穀物を手に入れて、
それは
かなりの製品を作ることができるので
、ジュースなどを追加することはでき
ませんが、4つの基本的な材料を手に入れた
ので、時間をかけてそれが何を
可能にするので、再びそれは彼らにとって素晴らしいことです.  4.4
生成作用を伴うフィードバック制御 概念はまだ
方程式 13 方程式 14 があります。
推論
は上記の方程式の形を認識します
14. 負の自由エネルギーまたは変分
下限として 議論のためにいくつかの引用を参照してください
目的は通常
、いくつかの同等の方法で書き出され、解釈されるため、
それぞれに
独自の直感が伴う可能性があり
ます ニューラル処理の過程でこの特定の発散
を最小限に抑える計算効率と熱力学的効率について
ラベルの証拠は
、動きのフィードバック修正にペナルティを
課すための他のより複雑な情報の相違を排除しないので、
期待される
自由エネルギーがあり、次に
期待される未来の自由エネルギーがあり、すべて
の これらのバリアントとそれらのエネルギーのそれぞれは
、教科書の方程式 2.6 の
ように異なる方法で分解できるため、
最初にどのようにし
てこの種のアバウンドにどのように収束したのか、
そしてなぜそれが
自由エネルギー原理
との共鳴を持たなければならないのか、そして何が つまり
、これらのエネルギー境界のさまざまな分割が、生き残るシステムについて考えるのにどのように役立つのでしょうか。
ここにダニエルを追加します。
慣れ親しんでいて、私は
彼らがこれを経験していたようなロックステップの方法に実際には苦労して
いませんでしたが、 方程式 13
と方程式 15 と 16 へのジャンプに到達するとすぐに、
私よりも頭の良い誰か
が、そのジャンプを本当に簡単な言葉で説明できなければならないでしょう。
私はまだそれがどのように機能するのか正確にはわから
ないので、ハンドヘルドが必要なので、著者は本当に
彼らの最も柔らかい手袋を持ってきたいと思うでしょう.
セクション4.4はまだ方程式15です.
セクション4.4は方程式16です.
ファンシー
J
方程式 14.
および
最適なフィードバック コントローラーのみの解析式
方程式 15 をベルマン方程式
方程式 12 に変換
すると、方程式 16 が得られます。
タームは
、より計算しやすい問題を生成します。
ファンシー
J のダイバージェンスタームは、正確に差として書くことができるため、まさにそのような方法を提供します。
Q star star sub Phi の下での扱いにくいハード最大値
と、事前に計画されたアクションの下でのより扱いやすいスムーズな最大値の間
シンボル方程式 17 の概念。かなり
興味深い わかりました
方程式 17 から
21 では、最後のセクション セクション 5 の
議論
多分あなたは私を助けることができます 今日、私たちは 13 歳
から 17 歳、そして 18 歳、19 歳、20 歳です。これ
は、スケール フリーの
形式主義を、スケールに固有の、または
スケールに適した
具体的な詳細と一緒にまとめる
ことができる方法です。 それを明確にしようと
する
のは素晴らしい
質問
です。あなたはグローバルについて話し
ます。彼らはそれを説明できなければ
ならないと思います。そう思いますが、
繰り返し
になりますが、突然物事が
溝に落ちたのです。
これが私が
最初のセクションで冒険したいこと
です.
ホメオスタシスとアロスタシスの対比
と、脳の神経解剖学と機能の
特定の分散モデルの下で報酬システムがもはや必要とされない方法についてです.
したがって、次の
形式は、拡張された
目的
を
、報酬の最大化によく使用されるベルマン方程式のような最適化お​​よび最適化フレームワークに置き換えると信じ
ているため
、山の頂上に到達することで報酬が得られるため、
パスに基づいて評価します
彼らがどれだけの報酬を獲得する
かについては、好奇心など
は、時間の経過とともにある程度価値があります.
地平線
は、高度の点で報酬を促進すると考え
ましたが、ここでは、pdfcdf関係による
最適な
操縦性の最大化のようなものへの動きが見られます.
ダイバージェンスをCDFの中間点に減らそうとする代わりに
、ログPDFを最大化するという点で応答性を最大化するのと同じように、
それは扱いやすい拡張um報酬関数だと思い
ます。その関数とその方法を指定する作業が残っています
おそらく
問題なく動作し
、セクション 5 のディスカッションの
インターセプトにより動作が安定し、
al が構築されます
5.1 脳を
アロスタティック最適コントローラーとして見る セクション 4
のアロスタティック経路積分制御
頂点モデルは、いくつか
の特定の仮説を暗示する
一般的なものから確率的最適制御へのそれらを超えて、
いくつかの議論があります アクティブな推論モデルを使用した共有
モデリングの選択肢は、おそらく apic がある種のアクティブな推論
モデル
と見なされるのに十分であり
、アクティブな推論モデルが
存在する場合でも厳密な意味でアクティブな推論モデルと共有される他のいくつかの機能
と、関連するモデリングの取り組みには
、追加するものは何もあり
ません。 いいえ、彼らはそれをここでかなり明確に綴っ
てい
ます.5.1はいくつかの予測
を提供し、頂点モデル5.2とのいくつかの対比を提供します.
制御理論のレンズを通して体と脳.
図6は内臓感覚データがどのように上昇するかを示しています.
X求心性
インターセプト予測エラーになるに
は、説明しますかbr つまり
、人々は用語集でそれを説明するかもしれないので、X富裕層が意味するものです
が、それは
基本的に動作信号の明らかな信号であり、
そこ
に何かを追加したいという少しの再帰があります。
求心性は
、神経のために内側または何かに向けて伝導または伝導
されます臓器が正しく供給した血管の中枢神経系で
あり、ええと
、正確な努力をどのように区別し
ますかそれはそのような
累積
的なものではなく、最初のようなものではありません
私が取り上げたの
はそれらの明らかな信号の蓄積です
興味深い
です あなたは間違っていると思います それは私が取ったもの
です 応答は
、最も驚くべき刺激のために予約されています。
Barrett 2017 からの提案
と 2013 年の dwark の発見 特定の
周辺インターセプターと人間は
、一定の刺激の下でオペラントの発火率をゼロに減らす
ので、
変化
がない場合はそれについて教えてくれず、それは
安いはずです 何か
があまり頻繁に変化しないモデル
であり、このアピック モデルで必須
であるそのような応答性の増加は
報酬として機能し、
行動の軌跡を積極的に強化する
一方で、応答性の低下は
マイナスのコストとして機能する可能性があるという仮説がいくつかあります。
行動の軌跡を強化
して無限の時間にわたってオプションを開いたままにしておく
ホライゾンは
、ビジネスを浮かせておく、または生理学を制限し続けることと同等になり
ます。
ええ
、米ドルまたはカロリーの量を
正しく最大化するのではなく
、範囲と軌道についての驚きを減らしたり制限したりして
、 ない戦略
このモデルでは、ここで述べた
ように、5.3 インターセプトと容量曲線を生成するために、
より多くの
5.4 結論 最後に、
アマチュア
ドッジボール プレーヤーに戻り
ます。 その扱いやす
さはディスカッションであり、付録 B の
エアコンについては以前に説明しましたが、
これはちょっとクールなトピックなので
、これらの付録
をスキップして、著者と議論するだけにします。
コントロールは
空気的に自由エネルギーの
原理につながる fep
詳細は付録 B 付録 C 頂点モデルの
導出 詳細は
方程式
C 0.1.2 最適値
関数と遷移ダイナミクスの
完全な導出
パス積分制御
などの一種の締めくくりの
メモ これがどのように
ベイジアン力学やベイジアン力学の 3 つの面
の右端にあるパスの定式化
にどのように接続するのか、また、
まったく異なる出発点
から、異なる
アプローチと制約を使用して、
いくつかの同様の機能
が発生し、apic で強調されている可能性があることについて疑問に思いました。
パス形式化のベイジアン力学にも強調表示され、関連しています。
そこに
は、マップされていないベン図のようなものがあるかもしれません。また
、偶然または意図
的に、最後のライブ ストリームに近いいくつかの類似点と相違点が、
あなたが見る方法になります。 この論文は
興味深いです。あなたが
締めくくり
たいと思うものは何でも
よく同意
しました
その他 リスク管理またはリスク最小化の
演習として、したがって制限戦略
またはオプション生成として
繰り返しますが、形式主義13とすべての間のジャンプを乗り越えるまで、APIモデルが両方のドメインで機能
するかどうかを実際に理解することはできません.
17 18 19 から 20 までの道のりです。
しかし、私はそれについての説明を意味し
、ええと、穏やかな刺激で
、それらが生理学的実体としての私たちであると思われるときに、それがどのように機能するかを知ることは興味深いでしょう.
リスク管理とオプション オプション
ジェネレーター オプションの拡張の両方を両立させることができるので、私は
実際に非常に興奮
して
います。
アロスタティックな観点からの次の賭け
私が言ったよう
に
、そのジャンプが彼らのモデルでどのように機能するかについてより良い感覚を得ることができれば、それは本当に
エキサイティングだと思います 無限の地平線の待機に対する最良の生理学的
決定
です。それは素晴らしい質問です。そうです
、永遠の今
の存在
、そして、もう少し
平凡なことに
、このタイプのモデルにどのような種類のデータが関連して
いるかは、すでに存在するデータです
まばらなデータセットから多くを推定できるものですか、
それとも
、モデル パラメーターの統計的信頼性を高め、自明ではない
調査結果を抽出するために大量の複製が必要ですか?
この
テクノロジーまたはアプローチはどこで使用されていますか? または、それを
どこで使用できるかについて話すの
は興味深いことがたくさんあり
ます。すべての準備と
この 1 つでの助けに感謝します。ディーンとドット 1 でお会いしましょう。